all right lauren
yeah lauren uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally san diego
california
san diego and uh tell me about your
family you had both your parents growing
up
um until i was about 12.
and uh what happened to 12. um my dad
had 17 years in the navy my mom said
uh i'm divorcing you and taking half and
dad said what's half nothing man and you
went where
um i stayed with my mom for a while
she was very authoritarian and a little
bit abusive um
so went to nebraska
hitchhiked nebraska is about 14. so you
ran away at a very young age
yeah um and when i came back uh
by the time i was 15 i was out of the
house living with my grandmother
living with your grandmother yeah okay
which was basically doing whatever
yeah did you finish uh high school no i
dropped out in the ninth
tenth grade ninth grade no no sexual
abuse when you were a kid
no um you know what did uh when i was
about seventh
uh neighbor boy uh
that was yeah my first experience sexual
experience
uh he had older brothers i guess that's
where he got educated but i don't
you know two seven-year-olds i don't
know if you'd consider that necessarily
abuse
i was pretty naive at the time yeah but
uh but you've always been gay you think
um but more closer by
right by your pan if it pans out
[Music]
so what have you done with your life
since you uh since you left out
your grandmother not much hustled and
worked carnivals
started a family and that just died
miserably so you're a carney
um yeah i'm show person okay and uh you
have family as well
uh you have a son yeah you have a son
yeah and uh you were married once
yeah but you're transgender now
yeah and when did that start to emerge
um
nine years seven eight so you you've
noticed
you've known this for a long long time
yeah i just recently just got a little
bit open about it
was it difficult for you to not be open
about it
for all those years yeah you know like
um
when my parents split up i was always
fighting
i realize it now just fighting for
acceptance and it's
this isn't what people did did you
your parents kind of saw some of this in
you and
i don't think so yeah um
then when i got out on my own it was a
you know
engine purge binge and purge uh
obviously i must have liked it because i
kept coming back to it
um when i got married
you know very seldom but yeah
even then and when i got went back to
work in the carnival it just
not necessarily you know
usually too busy yeah so tell me about
working in carnivals what is that like
um what did you do for the carnival
orange games
concessions so the little uh
uh you know rubber duckies uh throwing
darts
popping balloons yeah
how many years have you done that uh
about
20 plus travel all over the country
doing that
oh yeah absolutely um matter of fact i
stopped here to get my
id three weeks before cardo vid and i
was heading out to new york
three weeks before what college started
oh i see so kovit kind of put a stop to
the
carnival season yeah and i figured why i
was here uh
might as well just hang out for a little
bit so you're fairly new to san
francisco
yes yeah are you liking san francisco
um overall it's okay um
i come through in the late 80s uh
i was here for a couple hours you know
over on hayton ashbury
on way to go see a dead show and uh
it's not the same place i remember yeah
but being
being trans here probably is it's more
accepted than yeah uh
that has definitely been a plus to it
right why i decided to hang out for so
long yeah and you you have a
you have a son you said yeah how's your
son uh
almost 30. it was seven and he's
tell me about your son um
we just basically reunited after about
17 years 18 years uh
when me and his mom split grandma didn't
like me and uh
yeah it was just real bitter
so i went back to work on the carmelo
i haven't even met go back to san diego
in
20 plus years well i think
but uh do you talk to your son uh yeah
uh facebook how's your relationship with
him um
he's got problems uh
i mean he's a grown man he can do what
he wants
it's just hard to watch some of the
decisions he's making
is it uh drugs yeah yeah heroin
heroin yeah and uh drugs are part of
your life as well
um i smoke weed uh
you know long hours in the carnival but
he went carnival people sleep
in november so yeah
stimulus like like uh speed
speed yeah yeah how long how long you've
been using speed or crystal math
since i was 14 oh really yeah
i started you know yeah i think the
carny crowd
yeah it takes to that drug don't they um
yeah
that crack basically anything yeah
um my
thing brown is always to do do what you
do just handle what you do
yeah um dear friends
a few yeah you do um
mate you know why i'm here in san
francisco
uh i got a lot of friends on the road
that you know
they're scattered across the country
right
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your years of doing all this
um does my own self be true
um you're doing that yeah
if it doesn't feel right don't do it you
know um
at the end of the day you know you still
got to look at yourself you still got to
live with yourself
are you do you think you're happier this
way than you were
um it's
it i don't know necessarily happier
would be the word for it uh
it's definitely liberating and uh
felt free i feel free and more alive
than i have in years
and you've been trans for how long
um when i say it started when i
just about nine yeah you started
dressing as a woman
yeah yeah you know here and there
[Music]
since i've been here i've uh pretty much
devoted myself to it becoming more open
about it
yeah yeah um
contemplating you know where it's going
you know where it's gonna go in my life
at the moment
yeah do you feel like you've been loved
in your life by your parents or
my grandmother your grandmother my
grandmother yeah yeah
i miss her and you you were born this
way you believe right
yes yeah um
[Music]
it wasn't a choice uh matter of fact
i've tried
making conscious choices not to be
yeah because a lot of society sees it as
wrong right right right
um from the religious down to
you know joe schmoe on the street the
homeless aren't really accepting of it
uh do you feel you get like
treated badly because you're trans on
the street
um being in the carnival industry the
outdoor amusement
industry yeah no worse than that
um you know you pull into a town you're
instantly hated
so they either love you
they hate you so i mean it's i've dealt
with that my whole life
where are you living today you're um in
a shelter
uh the navigation center okay
um it's
run by uh former inmates so it's
kind of weird um
you can definitely tell the people that
bothers and
such but uh
in living this this unusual lifestyle
living as a
as a carney and and now as a trans
gender woman living on the street in san
francisco what
what what experiences have you had good
or bad
um pee
the people and you know it seems like
the homeless
seems to be part of it seems to be more
the issue
um you know i had you had no more
choices that
you know and considering when i showed
up and what's going on right now then
i do anything you know about my
sexuality or my [ __ ] gender
um with that said and you know it's
just bigotry it's just taking another
form yeah
do you have romantic uh partners um
i've had a couple since i've been here
uh
not not nearly enough
is that is that stuff you do for money
or just you meet somebody and you like
them and
it goes to there yeah um i
would do it for money you know the
opportunity you did as well sometimes
um i would yeah absolutely why not i
enjoy it and
might as well get work at something you
enjoy i know that sounds bad doesn't it
depends on how you look at it where do
you see your life going from here
um i don't know
i really don't um but you're happy yeah
uh
with the whole things that are going on
right now it's
you know don't be stupid but you know
you kind of got to live life for the
moment
um i've always kind of been like that
um all right lauren thank you so much
for talking with me yeah
good luck with uh wherever you go from
here and i hope your current season
gets back in gear all right thank you
thank you
you